Jonathan P gave me an Insight where he
said that the blades of grass in heaven
are are so are too sharp for man I just
thought oh man like I can think about
that for well I will be thinking about
that for months I'm so influenced by the
Eastern thought the viic tradition which
says that this is somehow ucer people
love and I think El the the tendency for
us to love
ucer is actually a self-loathing yes I
don't think that it's a search for
knowledge I don't I also don't think I'm
a truth Seeker I'm not a truth Seeker I
think I'm a selfish person who's just
curious just can't help himself here and
there and I'm I'm craving and I'm ugly
and I'm not courageous and I'm and I'm
an invertebrate and gutless like like
I'm a coward I am because I know what
I'm I'm afraid of there's some truths
that that are frightening